[Music]
every year grandkids cousins
pretty much everyone gets together even
grandma cocoa I tell her pretty much
everything like this some more I mean
see what I thought you said the animals
winters has begun it's the one night of
the year
our ancestors can come visit us I
thought I might've been one of those
made up things at a time
good night is about father
I am not like the rest of my family
there's something that makes me
different great-great-grandfather I
wanna be a musician just like you all
right moving uh I'm sorry
welcome to the land of your ancestors we
gay we're your family your skeletons
your eyes
[Music]
gotta get home before sunrise or you'll
be stuck well crap forever
oh come on it's so time
[Music]
you my boy are meant to be a musician I
must follow my heart
[Music]
I am trying to save your life rescue me
something's not good more than you'll
see
sorry
we may have our differences but
nothing's more important than family
I'm proud we're totally
[Music]
go wait you go it's just grunting never
named a street dog they'll follow you
forever now go get my shoe
[Music]